[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
32 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy, and I'm
here with my colleague Mark.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
Very excited about today.
We're going to be
talking with some people
with weird accents like you.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we're going
to be talking to some people
down in New Zealand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Some Kiwis.
And we're going to
be talking about how
they use two different-- two
completely different Google
products, actually.
They're going to-- they
use Google Cloud Platform
concretely.
BigQuery--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --but
also Google Analytics.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's a really
interesting conversation
about how they combine
those two things together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very interesting.
I definitely learned a lot,
so I hope that you will also
enjoy it down there.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But before that--
actually, not before
that, but at the end
we will also be talking about
the question of the week that
comes from someone that
asked you this question.
MARK MANDEL:
Actually, he'd asked
one of our teammates,
which leads
into one of his blog posts
that we'll talk about later.
But some cute little
tidbit to round off
Engine Flex, and some nice
little best practices for--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: [INAUDIBLE]
flexible environment.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Previously
known as managed VMs?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now a
flexible environment.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
we'll be talking about those
a little bit, too, at the end.
But before that,
we're going to start
with a cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is pretty exciting stuff.
So this cool thing of the
week is all around GRPC.
If you're not
familiar with GRPC,
it's a remote procedure
call framework
based out of some work
that's come out of Google.
It's pretty awesome.
I'm a huge fan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
know what GRCP stands for?
I think we've
covered this already.
MARK MANDEL: Isn't GRPC
remote procedure framework?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
It's a fractal
name, which I love.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Perfect.
There's a really interesting
blog post that came out
from a company called Dgraph.
They have an open
source graph database
that they write using GRPC.
And they talk about
actually how they go from--
and originally using
just the go/rpc,
so they use Go as
their primary language.
But they ended up wanting
to replace it with GRPC.
But the interesting part of
it is so GRPC uses protobuf.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
By default. Indeed.
MARK MANDEL: By
default. Which is cool.
But you can actually
switch it out.
And because of
certain tradeoffs they
wanted to make with sort of
message-side server sending
and what they were doing
on both ends of the pipe,
Flat Buffers was a
better fit for them.
And so they talk about why
they made that decision
and how they ended
up switching it out,
because in GRPC you can switch
out what your encoding type is,
which is really awesome.
And they sort of step
through all of that.
It's a really, really
interesting read
about taking that
open source project
and just extending it in the
way it was meant to be extended.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I actually like
a lot the blog post,
because it's very,
very, very code-rich,
which I really appreciate.
They describe a little
bit what they're doing,
but also they just give
you how they're actually
doing it, with all the
code, all the detail.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which I love.
Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: I love the fact
that they are like, hey,
this is what it looks like
using [INAUDIBLE] RPC in Go.
Here's all the lines of code.
And then here's the,
like, 10 lines of code
that we now use for GRPC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, it looks pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: So,
well worth a read.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We'll have a link to that
blog post in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Excellent.
So we are having a great
chat with Emily and Lester
from New Zealand at Trade Me.
Shall we move to
chatting with them?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go for that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
Today, we have the
distinct pleasure
of being joined by two wonderful
people from New Zealand,
very close to my
old home country.
We're joined today by Emily
Melhuish and Lester Litchfield
from Trade Me.
How are you both doing today?
How are you doing today, Emily?
EMILY MELHUISH:
Pretty good, yeah.
Just another day.
MARK MANDEL: Another day.
And you, Lester?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
So thank you so
much for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
Does one of you want to give
us a little bit of background
on say, like, who you
are and what you do?
Why don't we start
with you, Lester?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Sure.
My name's Lester.
I'm a data scientist slash
web analyst at Trade Me.
That means I help a
lot with things like AB
testing, stats, and also
helping to build products
that incorporate data, fault
protection, text processing,
those sorts of things.
And also pretty deeply involved
in the web analytics side
of things, so helping
tell the story of how
are users behave so that
people in our business
can build stuff that
makes them happy.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And you, Emily?
EMILY MELHUISH: Hi.
I'm Emily.
I'm a [INAUDIBLE]
developer here at Trade Me.
So I do a lot of C Sharp code.
So I work on both the back end
and the front end of the site.
I also am studying electrical
engineering at the same time,
because I like software
and hardware equally.
At the moment, I'm doing a
lot of work around big data
and how to get big data
to our other businesses,
and also provide insights
for our analytics people.
And yeah, it's just been
very interesting to work
in data analytics, but sort of
from a developer's perspective,
and making our business insights
a lot easier for us here
at Trade Me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So why don't you tell us and
our listeners a little bit
about Trade Me?
What do you do?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: So Trade Me
is a pretty interesting company
in that it started
off as a marketplace,
but has grown to be a sort of
way of life in New Zealand.
So not only like pretty much
everybody in New Zealand
uses Trade Me to
buy and sell stuff--
we're a nation of cheapskates,
we love getting a bargain--
but also we've expanded into
other verticals, as well.
So we're one of the leading job
websites in the country, one
of the leading auto
of the leading real estate
sites in the country.
So we're pretty broad-spanning
big fish in a small pond,
if you like.
So that's a bit about Trade Me.
EMILY MELHUISH: Yeah.
We have-- like in New
Zealand, we're pretty big.
We have something like 60%,
I think, of the web traffic.
And we have a lot of
people using us a day.
I guess like, to America, we're
kind of like Amazon or eBay,
one of those sort of sites, but
just solely for New Zealand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Did you just say
that you get 60% of the
traffic in New Zealand?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: That's
a bit of a dodgy stat.
It's a--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, know,
that is pretty impressive.
Just curious.
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, we were like
the highest traffic
site in New Zealand
for quite some time.
We're still the second
highest from Nielsen Stats.
That's just below one
of the major news sites.
So yeah, we're a phenomenally
big proportional amount
of the traffic in New Zealand.
EMILY MELHUISH:
Yeah, definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
OK, cool.
So I know you do some
interesting things
with big data, as well as with
Google Analytics integration.
Do you want to talk to
us about how you use
Google Analytics at Trade Me?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Sure.
So Google Analytics is our
web analytics platform.
We use it for heaps of things.
One, to understand where people
come from to get to the site.
Number two, what
they do when they
get there, what sort
of pages they're using,
what parts of the
products they find useful,
what sort of interactions lead
on to kind of goal completions
or things we want people to do.
We also use it to measure and
attribute our marketing spend,
and we use it to test things
like conversion funnels,
how people move
through processes.
And then right to the end
of the chain, so the value
and the outcomes that
different kinds of people
are contributing
to the business.
So we use it across all
of our sites and apps.
So that's a desktop website,
a mobile site, and about five
or six different apps.
EMILY MELHUISH: And so
for our side of things,
we also use Google
Analytics to provide
business-to-business insights.
So all of our customers like
car dealers, real estate agents,
we provide analytics to them on
their sort of houses and cars,
and how all they are
faring on Trade Me.
LESTER LITCHFIELD: One of
the awesome things about GA
is that you're able
to take information
from lots of different sites
and apps and roll it up into one
big master account.
So in Emily's case,
a motors dealer
can find out how
their products are
being interacted with across
all of our sites and platforms.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Is there any particular features
of Google Analytics that you
use to do this sort of stuff?
EMILY MELHUISH: So
very recently, Lester
has been using Google
Tag Manager in addition
to Google Analytics.
And so that-- in addition to--
so Google Analytics gives you--
you know, you can get the
source, the location of where
people are coming
from, but it doesn't
have things that are quite
custom to car dealers,
say like the vehicle
model and the vehicle
ID, or anything like that.
So we use Google Tag
Manager to provide what's
called custom dimensions.
So on every page view
or click or event,
we send through a
whole bunch of data
all about what, say,
that vehicle is.
That then gets sent
into Google Analytics,
which we can then provide-- we
can use to provide insights on.
So in addition to
basic web data,
you can get more specific stuff.
So Google Tag Manager
is really good,
and really easily ties
into Google Analytics.
LESTER LITCHFIELD:
Yeah, it's pretty cool.
You can put a-- Google Tag
Manager works around a data
layer, so this content
that on the client side
you have this array or this
dictionary which just holds
heaps of data about what's
going on at the time in, like,
a key value store.
So you have the name of the car
dealer, the color of the car,
and all those sorts of things.
You know, sometimes up to
30 or 40 different things.
And then any actions they
happen on their page,
like a click or a page
view or an interaction,
you can pick which
ones of those you'd
like to grab,
bundle that all up,
and send it as a hit
to Google Analytics.
So it's super flexible, and it
enables you to pretty easily
pass pretty rich data around.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So basically, if I
understand correctly,
what you're doing is you're
sending a bunch of information
to Google Analytics, you're
tagging it in different ways.
What happens with it afterwards?
How do you process it?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Well,
mainly you process it.
[LAUGHTER]
Then it's provided to us
in all these lovely kind
of built-in reports.
But increasingly now we're
starting to use integration
with BigQuery.
The reason that's really
cool is because it gives us
access to the raw data.
It's totally unsampled, and it
enables us to do kind of ad hoc
or pretty complex queries
without having to really worry
about compute power.
We don't have the
resource internally
to look over a year's weblogs
in a reasonable timeframe,
but you guys do.
So that's sort of
how we're using it.
And Emily can talk
a little bit more
about how she's been using
the BigQuery API, which
is really cool, the fact
that that massive, massive
datastore, where it's about
like 30, 40 gigs a day
of logs we export to BigQuery
is all available right
behind an API for her
to be able to kind
of consume and aggregate
or expose on the website.
MARK MANDEL: I'll take you
back a step just real quick,
as well.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about what
does that process look like
for taking Google Analytics
and pushing it to BigQuery?
Is it like just a checkbox,
or is there a lot of work?
Like, what had to happen there?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: It was
sort of part of the GAP deal,
really.
It was offered to
us as a feature,
and we thought, oh, yeah,
that kind of looks cool.
So we said yeah,
go ahead, do that.
So they set up a
cloud project for us.
And then a little bit
later, we were like, hey,
we should have a look.
And when we had a look,
we were like, wow,
this is pretty impressive.
Not only is there heaps of
data there-- and especially
with the custom dimension
stuff, it's really rich--
but also the processing
power is not like anything
we've seen before.
It's sort of the
power of Grayskull,
really, when you [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
got the reference.
I'm so proud right now.
MARK MANDEL: You
mentioned a GAP deal.
I don't know what that means.
Do you want to explain that?
LESTER LITCHFIELD:
Google Analytics Premium.
So it's just the difference
between the free one, which
is you have a lot of
your data sampled down
for obvious reasons
that, you know,
when half the web is
using it for free,
it's pretty hard to provide
loads of processing power
for that, to the paid version.
So the paid version gives you
kind of unsampled reports,
and also these integrations
into BigQuery and other kind
of premium features.
EMILY MELHUISH: I think that
the best way Lester described
it a few months back was that
Google Analytics was for kids,
and then BigQuery was for
the grown-ups, because it's
like the real, raw data in
there that you've got to query.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah,
Emily, Lester was sort of
sending it over to
you to talk about how
you use the BigQuery API.
Do you want to talk a
little bit about that?
EMILY MELHUISH: Yeah, sure.
So when we first started with
BigQuery, it was kind of new,
and there wasn't much
documentation on how
people were using it.
So we spent a lot of time trying
to figure out how to use it.
Eventually, of course,
thankfully there
is an awesome API
that we can use.
But obviously, the awesome
thing about BigQuery
is you can run massive queries
in a few seconds' time.
However, we were looking at
providing business insights
for our customers,
and we sort of
wanted a dashboard to load
within a few microseconds as
opposed to-- or
milliseconds as opposed to,
you know, five seconds that--
as a data analytics person,
you wouldn't mind,
but customers might
get frustrated having to wait
for data to come through.
And because BigQuery,
I believe, have, like,
a one-second minimum query.
So as we have so much
data in BigQuery,
we had to figure out a way
to get what we wanted out,
and be able to query it
quickly and get the data
to our customers, basically.
So for that, what we did is
we set up a scheduled app
with the BigQuery API.
And basically every day, we'd
go to the massive table, which
I think is about
3.3 million rows,
and we basically
query, OK, give me
all of these people's
listings on Trade Me,
and give me all of the data.
And we export that
into our own database.
And then from there, we
can have our web app talk
to our database and pull out
the data very, very quickly.
So that was a pretty
good way to do it.
And it means we can run
the scheduled app at, say,
3:00 AM in the morning.
It'll be done in about, I
think, 30 seconds, usually.
And usually we're adding,
say, about 30 gig of data.
So every day, to get all of
the listings that we need,
it's about 30 gig
of data putting
into it, which is quite a bit.
And I think when I
was-- I usually, like,
play around with things
to get the queries right.
And I think the best query I
got was 480 gigabits of data
to be queried.
And I think it did it in, like,
45 seconds or something crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
EMILY MELHUISH: That
was pretty awesome.
MARK MANDEL: So
basically, from what
I understand, you're
basically pulling down
aggregate information
from BigQuery?
Would that be pretty accurate?
EMILY MELHUISH: Yeah.
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Yeah.
EMILY MELHUISH: Definitely.
LESTER LITCHFIELD:
Yeah, because it's
got that level of granularity.
And sometimes you want to
go deep into that nesting.
It's really
interesting, actually,
coming from a SQL background
and doing a lot of SQL queries
where you go-- you know, the
longer you go down your table,
the longer your query takes.
But going down in
BigQuery is easy.
It's going-- right?-- so
increasing down the levels
of nesting.
So I'm still not really sure
whether the BigQuery table
structure is SQL
or non-SQL-like,
because it gives you a tabular
format, but it's nested
and you've got a
lot of-- it looks
almost sparse because
you've got a lot of nulls.
So it's some kind of NoSQL
sparsity-cum-tabular data
format.
And there's a few tricks to kind
of being able to pull up data
from the lowest level of
nesting to the highest, which
had been fun to learn about.
But yeah, it works brilliantly.
MARK MANDEL: So Lester,
I'm quite curious, too.
Like, you're a data scientist.
How has having access to all
that data inside BigQuery
changed your job in terms of
how you interact with Trade
Me and the data it provides?
LESTER LITCHFIELD:
Well previously, we
would be able to get very
limited numbers of answers.
We'd go, oh, is your
question addressable
by one of our metrics?
And sometimes, we'd have to
get a half answer by, like,
doing, like, 30 queries
and joining them up.
But now, like, pretty much
with Google Tag Manager,
every click is basically
available to be tracked.
And with BigQuery, any kind
of condition or process,
or basically anything, is there.
So it takes the
pressure off the data,
and means that
answering the questions
is about how good are you as
a data scientist at framing
the question and bringing
through the answers in a kind
of clear and-- so it puts
the pressure on the science
rather than the data.
EMILY MELHUISH:
It's also very easy
to have a slight mishap
somewhere in the data.
And if that happens, a
lot of your reporting
does some interesting things.
So in our scheduled app,
which basically queries
all of the BigQuery data,
what we actually had to set up
was a lot of sort of like tests
to check that the data was
still coming through correctly.
So that was quite cool.
And the BigQuery API allows
us to do that pretty easily,
and has quite good logging
and everything for that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Also, Lester, you mentioned
you do a lot of AB testing.
I know Google Analytics has some
system tools and capabilities
built into that.
Is that changed as well
within BigQuery, now
that you have that power,
or is it still the same?
How are you doing that?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: We sometimes
use Google Analytics content
experiments.
And they work really well in
a sort of a certain scope.
Like my favorite thing
is that it wraps some,
like, on further reading,
pretty meaty Bayesian stats
in a really nice wrapper,
so you don't really
have to think about it.
Unfortunately,
sometimes you do have
to think about it because
the framework doesn't quite
fit for the question you have.
And the cool thing
about BigQuery
is, like, we use Python
quite a lot internally,
and so I can go into Python,
pull out some aggregates
from BigQuery, and then run any
kind of statistical processing
over that from, say, [INAUDIBLE]
or SciPy or any of those kind
of big scientific libraries.
So it means that yeah, you
get the freedom to kind of do
AB testing however you
want based on the data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I was wondering,
at some point
you were talking about the fact
that the way you use BigQuery,
since BigQuery has
that one-second minimum
for a request, what you do
is you store some aggregates
into some temporary database.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about that?
Where is that database running?
What kind of database is this?
EMILY MELHUISH: Yeah, sure.
So for us here at
Trade Me, we have
quite a lot of different
databases everywhere.
So we do have one big
database that stores basically
like the last day's data.
So what happens
is because there's
a bit of delay between getting
everything flowing from Trade
Me to Google Tag Manager
to Google Analytics
then into BigQuery,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
to query that, we usually get,
like, the last-- yesterday's
data.
And so what happens is that
all gets-- so in BigQuery,
each day is a new table.
And so what happens each day for
us is we append each day's data
to our database.
And we only hold about 90
days of data at a time.
So basically, because
for business insights
we don't report back
on 90 days, obviously,
but if someone,
say, wants to report
on a year's worth
of data, what we do
is we then go to BigQuery,
since the data is already there.
So basically, we effectively
cache 90 days of data.
And then, in BigQuery,
if we want more data,
they just have to wait
more time to sort of get
90 days plus whatever
more of data.
So that's quite good
for us to store the data
that we want immediately.
But then if they want
more, they can take more.
Sorry, they're in MySQL tables.
MARK MANDEL: I'm curious, do
you run your own infrastructure?
I don't know how good the cloud
providers are in New Zealand.
How does that,
like, locality work?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Sure.
Yeah, we run our
own infrastructure.
So we have boxes.
Yeah.
Remember those days.
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah, we have
a ton of boxes.
We're not sort of super
distributed as a model.
Like we sort of-- we're largely
on a kind of Microsoft stack.
So this is where it's
quite interesting for us,
even beyond analytics, when you
get into the data processing
where the distributed models
start to make a lot of sense,
that we may begin to [INAUDIBLE]
looking into how the Google
Cloud Platform can help provide
some of that distributed
kind of processing power.
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm guessing you've
got local machines, because
latency, and because, you know,
your audience is right there.
But then when that
immediate speed thing is not
necessary as much when
you're looking at,
like, how do we
elastically scale our data
processing, that's
when you're sort
of stepping into the cloud.
Would that be correct?
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Yeah.
I mean, the nearest
AWS is in Sydney,
and the nearest Google data
center I think is in Singapore.
So Singapore to New
Zealand is quite far.
Like, it's probably like bigger
than the continental United
States.
So it's quite far.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That's actually a
very interesting way
of using-- basically you're
using the cloud for the part
that interests you, and
the rest [INAUDIBLE].
EMILY MELHUISH: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Well, I think that we are
almost running out of time.
So is there anything
that you'd like
to add that we have
not mentioned before?
EMILY MELHUISH: OK, I
have two cool things.
One cool thing, because with
BigQuery you can basically
narrow down on really,
really distinct stats
and data about a certain
view, and so with our tests
that we run when we're querying
the BigQuery API to check
the validity of the data,
there was a few times
when the whole of the data
layer and the custom dimensions
were null, but there
was still a view logged.
So it was kind of interesting,
and it was quite fun
because we got to be all, like,
CSI detective to see, like,
why is this happening.
And what we actually
managed to find
was that there was a
whole bunch of listings
hit at the exact same timestamp
with the exact same browser ID.
And they hit all
of these listings.
And so what we actually
managed to find out
is that these were
obviously bots,
like, scraping through the site.
And they obviously went
through it fast enough
that the data layer
didn't have time
to populate and be
sent to GTM properly.
So that was pretty interesting.
And I think I was
on Skype with Lester
being like oh my gosh,
there's these bots, ah!
And so he was like, oh,
block their browser IDs.
And it was kind of cool.
It was a little wee
detective moment
to sort of be like, oh, bots,
and block them from our data
so they don't sort
of mess with it.
So I thought that was pretty
awesome to see that happening
and then be able to sort of stop
them from affecting our data.
That was pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Lester,
you got anything?
LESTER LITCHFIELD:
Nothing that cool.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is fine.
Well, I think we're
running out of time,
so thank you very much for
taking the time to chat
about Trade Me with us today.
EMILY MELHUISH: Thank
you for having us.
LESTER LITCHFIELD: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you so
much again, Emily and Lester,
for such an
interesting interview.
I hope you learned
as much as I did.
It was very
interesting to see how
two different pieces of Google
can collaborate together
to make analytics even better.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I mean, I've only personally
ever just kind of plugged
[INAUDIBLE] Google Analytics and
just kind of let it sit there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Not really
doing well with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
mean, that's what
we do with the podcast, really.
Like, we have Google Analytics
as like the most basic thing
we can do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So it's actually
really interesting
to see how people are kind of
pushing the envelope in terms
of what you can do with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Maybe you should add some of
those features to the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe
you should add them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah. [INAUDIBLE]
requests are welcome.
Anyway.
So let's move on.
Let's go with the
question of the week.
But actually, before we do
the question of the week,
there was a little cool thing
of the week, which is maybe
we should create a
new section, which
is not cool thing of the week,
it's a cute thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: It is
pretty adorable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is the most
adorable guide to Kubernetes
I've ever seen.
The name is the "Illustrated
Children's Guide
to Kubernetes."
And if you have
a kid and the kid
wants to learn how
to use Kubernetes
and what it is, and
loves like cartoons
and giraffes and cute gophers,
it is just the perfect video.
MARK MANDEL: Or really if
you're just a kid at heart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know I'm
going to watch it later.
MARK MANDEL: It is really--
you definitely should watch it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is very, very cute.
So we'll also have a link to
that one on the show notes.
It is adorable.
But now for real
we're going to go
with the question
of the week, which
was about App Engine Flex, App
Engine flexible environment.
So what was the question?
MARK MANDEL: So the question
was around how do you shut down
an App Engine flex project.
Like say you're
prototyping or trying
something out, maybe a proof of
concept, something like that.
You don't want to have
it running all the time.
Now, one of the tradeoffs
with App Engine Flex
is you get a lot
more flexibility,
you can do whatever you want,
but it doesn't scale to zero.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So you might
want to shut it down.
Now previously, this
was kind of tricky.
You had to kind of jump
through some loopholes
and do some fun things,
and it wasn't great.
The great thing is now
there's a simple command that
allows you to do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And what is the command?
MARK MANDEL: So it's a
version-specific command.
So you're like, hey, I want
you to shut down this version.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So you can
say GCloud preview app
version stop, and
then the version
name you want to shut down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
It sounds simple.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty simple.
So you can kind of work on
something for a few hours,
or your day.
And then once you're done at the
end of the day, shut it down.
Then you don't have to
worry about paying for it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
That sounds, like,
very useful, especially
if you are-- like once your
application is in production
and people-- you actually have,
like, real traffic, please
don't do that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's a bad idea.
But if you're just
getting started
and you're working on it,
like, once a week and stuff
like that, yeah,
it's probably worth
saving couple cents in there.
MARK MANDEL: Well, it's
really cool, actually.
One of our teammates, Sandeep,
wrote a whole blog post
that we'll put in
the show notes just
discussing like how to make
savings, like cost savings
when doing prototyping or proof
of concepts with App Engine
Flex.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And you go through
some best practices and things
you can do to really
bring those costs down
until you're ready to bring
in, like, all that real traffic
and have that come in.
So well worth a read.
We'll put that in
the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: So I
think that kind of
brings to an end all of our
stuff for today, Francesc.
Are you going to be anywhere
special in the next few weeks?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, yes.
Next week, that will be--
actually not next week,
but the week after that, I will
be in Denver for GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very excited about that.
It is one of my
favorite conferences.
So I'm going to be very, very
excited to be able to do--
MARK MANDEL: And I
believe you're doing
something pretty special there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm kind
of doing an opening keynote,
it seems.
So that's going to be--
MARK MANDEL: Just
a little something.
Just a little something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
a little something.
Yeah.
It's going to be fun
to be on stage and see,
like-- I think it's 1,500
gophers looking at you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah, that's what
nightmares are made of.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
Just remember to--
just remember,
you know-- I don't know.
Don't do anything
too embarrassing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, we'll see.
What about you?
What are your plans?
MARK MANDEL: So when
this podcast releases,
the day after that, I will be
in New York for Playcrafting
in New York.
There's going to be
a Google panel there.
And I have some other
events coming up.
Nothing is quite confirmed
yet, so we'll see what happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, you can tell us
more next week then.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thanks so much again.
Thank you, Mark, for sharing
the time here today with me.
And thank you all our
listeners for being there.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And again, if you have
questions, comments, concerns,
you feel like just
saying hi, love
having people do that sort
of stuff and let us know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
love people saying hi.
MARK MANDEL: We love people.
Yeah, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well,
see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]